hi guys it's silverette again and I have
a little announcement to make uh because
I've almost got 5,000 subscribers and
that's awesome
and it's not your turn yet okay and um
basically I didn't know anything to do
so I'm going to do a q& a so it'd be uh
if you have any question you want to ask
me uh you can leave a comment in the
comment section below and I'll answer it
in the video and um yeah it can be the
weirdest stuff I might even do a face
cam I don't know if you know people ask
for that yeah because no one has seen
your face yet and stuff yeah same yeah
that's that's only if you guys don't
share it around which you keep doing and
yeah I think that's pretty much it also
it'd be awesome if you guys would
actually be awesome and leave comments
so I I'm not here saying guys please
leave comments and then have an empty
comment SE guys Ju Just leave him alone
it's going to be funny yeah so um bye
I'm looking forward to seeing your
comments